so hi everyone and thank you for coming
my name is Adi and I work here at PayPal
as a data scientist and my job is to
develop machine learning algorithms for
fraud detection now PayPal is known for
being a safe and secure and however
maintaining this reputation requires
hard work behind the scenes of
developing fraud detection algorithms so
think about our problem as we have a
transaction payment and we want to
detect if it is fraud or not now as our
algorithms perform better and better in
production we understand that we want
more the final model score is not enough
for us and we want to understand the
story behind the model decision so think
about this example an inconclusive score
the model predicts 50% chance for this
transaction to be fraud ok why we want
to understand is it further or not we
don't really know what to do with 50%
chance so for example if we could break
this model score into how much every
feature contributes to the decision we
can get more insights so for example
here maybe there is inconsistency with
past activity maybe the user connects in
a different time of day than she usually
Shops at so this can increase the fraud
chance and however she does use her own
credit card and she sent the product to
her house so that decreases the front
chances and we reached that point 5
decision when having all this in our
mind we can get more interesting
insights about this transaction maybe
this is a traveling customer therefore
the inconsistency but it's the same
person so this type of explanation is
part of the law
field of explain ability I this is a
huge buzz word coming up and it's the
next big thing I think in machine
learning and I am personally very
excited about that and to explain our
models can help it can help us a lot to
get more data insights to the back cover
models understand when they are wrong
why and maybe improve our own modeling
process because if we train a model and
we just check on the test at the back
teeth we don't know what is really going
on there so okay we are good in genius
but if we understand why our models do
and then we can change them according to
our analysis we can get much better
models in a place to maybe less time and
this specific type of explanation that
they show you here breaking the model
score into feature traditions
this is called local editing feature
importance and it can be calculated
using shop shop goal system okay so shop
stands for shop we additive explanations
and it is a method for local feature
importance local because we explain a
specific instance at a time now the
input for shop is a training model F and
the specific instance X the output of
shop is an explanation for every feature
we get the contribution of this feature
to the model score f of X now this is
local we say we explain specific
instance at the time and it is also
additive because the sum of all
contributions is exactly f of X so our
goal in this talk is to understand how
she does this why is the type theory
behind
and also how can we leverage shop to get
insights about how a mother's shop
theory is exciting it is based on chakra
values from game theory they were
defined in the 50s by Lloyd sharply he
was an economist and mathematician and
he also won the Nobel Prize for
economics in 2012 so think about a game
this is a cooperative game played by a
few players together and then by the end
of the game they reach specific amount
of money the question is how do we
divide the money between these players
in a fair way assuming each player
contributed differently to the game so
what is a fair way Shapley first defined
fairness properties he defined that a
fair way it means an additive way it
means that the sum of the money the old
players get together should be the game
result and consistency that if one
player contributes more to the game she
cannot get less money the most exciting
thing in shop I think is the thing that
sharply values were proved to be the
only unique solution for distributing
this money keeping the fairness
properties of course we can assume it
the money however we want but if we want
to keep the furnace properties it must
be sharply buddies what are sharply
values now we go into the details
sharply values for player i sharply
value is the amount of money that this
player would get how do we calculate
this amount we count the marginal
contribution of this player it means
running the game with and without this
player but for every possible subset of
players again F is the game M is the set
of all players s is a specific subset
and we run over all possible subsets and
is our player that we want to decide how
money should she get so
take a specific subset of players now we
calculate the game result for this
subset with and without our player I and
then we do this averaging over all
subsets of players and this is shuffling
values and average okay now we're gonna
take this to the machine learning
settings and okay before I want to
highlight this is the only solution for
being a fair distribution of money this
was proved theoretically now we take it
to the machine learning settings and
this is the I think the exciting thing
that Scott Lambert and swingley from the
University of Washington published in
2017 they published their first trap
paper and they said we are going to
adapt chuckling values into the machine
learning settings now F is a model M is
the set of all features s is a subset of
features I is a specific feature and we
want to it to explain how do we give
this feature its importance its
contribution not to the game to the
model result okay
X should be the specific instance that
we explain as I said shop is a local
method we explain a specific input
instance at a time so we are now
explaining how much feature I
contributed to f of X so how we get we
take we count over all possible all
possible subsets of features and we
calculate the model result on the subset
with and without feature I we this okay
we we take the difference between those
two results with and without the feature
I and then we get a specific marginal
contribution we have rated over all
possible subsets of features and this is
the sharp value for player I a for
feature I so now by following the
definitions of Shapley values and this
is what sharp outers true
we are following the definitions of
chocolate values and therefore we are
the only unique solution to distribute
the contributions of the features by and
keeping the fairness property so this is
the only possible solution to keep our
additivity and consistency of the
feature attributions method okay that
sounds perfect perfect we have a very
good question
[Music]
this is a perfect question okay I'm just
talking about it okay so we have two
questions two main member big challenges
here first I told you we should count
for every possible subset of features
now every possible subset is an
exponential time and this is a problem
right it's not practical if we have a
large number of features of our model
the second problem is I told you and
this is exactly what you asked you
should run a model with missing features
I didn't say you put null I said missing
features no features how do you run a
model with part of the input is missing
this is a big problem and therefore we
need the chef's algorithms to solve it
and out this is what I'm going to
explain how do they solve in different
options these two problems for you to
have just an intuition what is the most
naive way you could calculate chop
values okay just train a different model
for every subset of features now if you
train a different model you can run it
with the features you trained and that's
it it's an exponential of course and you
have to train it's not practical but
this is very named and just for
intuition now actually this doesn't
solve our problem because I want to
explain my model in production if I
retrain a different model for every set
of features this is not explaining my
model this is explaining some feature of
the data some characteristic of the data
and now this is specific a very
interesting thing and if you want to
read more about it and
you should go to Edden say hi
Athens post I give here the link and
this is exactly the subtle issue he
explains okay
so let's focus we want to calculate
additive and locally accurate additive
feature attributions we want to keep the
fairness properties we want to calculate
the shop values but we have challenges
so how do we solve them so to our best
of luck this is exactly what sharp
package in Python does they just
implemented a few algorithms may
actually they implemented a lot of
algorithms I will explain a few of them
to solve these challenges so you can
peep install shop it has a very
user-friendly API actually as you seen
this piece of code you don't really have
to understand anything about what is
going on behind the same to apply shop
you just do shop dot something sharp
shock values blah blah blah you have the
shell values what I'm going to explain
is what is going on behind the scenes
which algorithm you want to choose what
do you have to supply as an input and
more interesting thing than just a
flight so the first algorithm I am going
to describe is the kernel explainer shop
kernel explainer is an algorithm which
is model agnostic you can apply to every
function it assumes nothing about the
model however it calculates only
approximation of the shaft values not
exact values why because instead of
going over all subsets of features
it's just sampled some of them so it's
an approximation and you decide how much
subset you want it increases your
runtime accordingly how do they deal
with the missing feature problem this is
more interesting in my opinion they just
say okay we cannot just reduce features
from our model so let's just replace
their values with with something that
you as the user tell us which is a
background you as the user should decide
what is your background data set and
this is interesting question I'm going
to do to describe here
and your supply it as an input to the
shaft fair method and it just replaces
values take the missing features that
you have by the shop in equation it
replaces now with features from your
background data set with values from
your background data okay so what bed
form data sets people use okay yeah I
just I have it here so thank you so
there for example people use their whole
training set now if I replace the values
for everything I have in my training set
you understand that it increases run
time also so maybe just a second you
maybe you want to do just a kit means
approximation of your data set or
something like this people use the
median of the data set if they
understand that this is a good
background or for example for images you
might choose an all-black image or
something like this but you should
decide what is your background and if
you don't decide you just run it with
something and you hope it's gonna be
fine
now the thing I wanted to highlight here
about the background is that there is a
story I cannot give you specific
instructions this is the background
introduces more things in explainable AI
this is an open question nobody really
has a real answer to how which
background should you use but I have a
story this story is a real story it's
taken from a github issue actually if
you're interested in shop values go to
the github issues and start reading them
people ask Kleinberg a lot of questions
and the answers very nice and
interesting and well answers and it's a
very good resource so this specific
issue after I incorporated it in my
presentation I understood that this the
person that asked this question easily
act and she's the researcher PhD student
in Bangor on doing the research about
explain ability
she couldn't come here but yeah this is
her question about the background
dataset so what is the question she said
I have a sparse data set for example I
have measurements of body parts of
measurements for data again from the
head so this is very sparse data and for
example I have a feature indicating if
this measurement is coming from the lung
or not now I want to explain an instance
a specific instance from the lung which
background should I use so if you choose
only lung background you're safe in
terms of the distribution you are not
going out of the distribution because
this is a long distribution this is
actually not true because in the
language you also can have some secret
senses and some requirements about the
distributions but let's say it's
simplified okay so however you want to
replace the East line feature with
something and you are not going to
replace it with anything other than one
because this is what you are having your
background so how would you understand
the impact of the Islamic feature if you
cannot replace it with anything else
however if you choose the old data set
as a background then you are safe in
terms of you are going to replace the
Islamic feature with zero but you might
go out of your distribution very very
fast and I'm not going to talk about it
this is a very big issue and I don't
have a solution okay so this is about
the current data set now another very
interesting thing about shop kernel
expert okay yeah so in short word the
question was can I explain the purpose
of the background dataset so the purpose
of the background data set is to provide
you values to replace missing input in
the shop formula you have to run your
model with some input missing you have
to sample subsets of features and when
you have a subset it means that part of
the features that are missing out from
your model and how do you run a model
with missing input you have to seek to
put something because the model should
mean something to run so the the option
for the option here that the shop
outdoors found
okay we just replace it with background
and those will mimic missing features I
didn't say that it is the best way but
this is their way so another very
interesting thing about kernel expeller
is the connection with lime lime is
another feature local feature
attributions method and actually it was
published a few years a year before shop
what line does is to train a linear
model that approximates our model but in
a very specific point in the local area
of our point that we want to explain
right this is a local method so they
train a linear model to approximate
their big model just in a specific area
of the of the of the distribution now
what is this area what does it mean Boca
so they have a kernel function to
describe locality but this kernel
function is not provided to you you
should use whatever you want this is a
knife a hyper parameter now shop others
proved that if you run line with their
specific kernel you are actually
calculating shaft values so this is the
connection between them and this is a
very interesting result because then
they can use the line implementation of
running linear regression on the area
around your model around your instance
and you with the locality of their
kernel and then you get shock values
okay another very interesting algorithm
is the three explainer now you can apply
it to only three based models by to
calculate exact check values in
polynomial time and this is a very very
interesting result how do they do it
intuitively how do you run a tree with
missing input so you traverse the tree
run right you traverse the tree to run
the model now you encounter a specific
split and your input is missing so you
don't know where where you do need to go
so you just go both ways and recursively
sum up the
Souths average the resultant this is
intuitively their algorithm to mimic
missing features in a tree and they keep
track of the tree traversal to avoid
repetitions and therefore they manage to
calculate all subsets
but in polynomial time because they
remember things in the middle okay so
this is a very elegant solution and if
your model is tree it could be random
forest it could be a gradient boosting
could be activist many many things are
supported you should first try this one
because if you should supply no
background and it runs the exact values
in polynomial time
so for trees this is better for deep
learning models for neural networks they
also provide a different algorithm and
this is really out of the scope of this
term because it's a very complicated to
describe I would just say the very basic
intuition they use a connection with
another algorithm which is called deep
lift they calculate shape values for
small parts of the network for example
just for the linear part just for a
nonlinear function with one input they
calculate analytically very many many
shaft values in the network and then the
deep list is being used to back broke-up
back propagate all of this knowledge of
these shock values locally to get some
values for your input so this is not a
good explanation how it works but this
is just an intuition and you are
encouraged to read papers okay so many
questions here
the question was if the results of shaft
values of of deep explainer is an
approximation yes it is an approximation
why because you should read like the
paper okay and you also should provide
some background data set but for
different reason and we can discuss
later okay so if you lost me so now you
should wake up this is my take home
story about the shop method about the
shop algorithms and then I'm going to
move to the practical part so we need
loca we want but actually we need local
additive feature attributions
many methods try to solve it I mentioned
lime I mentioned deep lift there are
much more however only a unique solution
can satisfy additivity and consistency
and this is the Shapley values
calculating exact chaplet values is hard
shot provides approximation for all
models all possible models in an
approximation with the kernel explainer
and considering tree based algorithms
you can calculate exact Chapel use in
polynomial time do it and for new
networks you can use the dip explainer
which uses some connection with the deep
lift algorithm okay perfect right
woohoo okay now if you are going to use
shock values you should just know that
if you have a lot of or some correlated
feature in your data set you can get
unexpected results
I will give just one short intuition now
because we don't have a lot of time but
for example if your model has two
identical features I just replaced the
name but it's two identical features
trained on the label now if my model
uses just one of them
so shop would attribute all the value to
the first our first feature x1 and x2
would get 0 shop values however if the
model uses both sometimes x1 sometimes
x2 you cannot control it you can try but
not every time you can control which
correlated feature your model uses so
then you might get your shop value split
into two and if you have not two
correlated features maybe you have ten
because you have I don't know thousands
features for your model then your shop
values might be split into very very
very small amount and then your gonna
think that this picture is not important
because it has a low shot value and it's
not true so the cash shop is additive
you can sum up things together and it's
it's fine
you
do it so maybe this is a solution but
you should think about it good okay this
is the practical part what do we do
after we calculate safaris so now I will
mention one thing this is also an open
question I didn't see many people
talking about what do they do with shop
values maybe they calculate them and
just show them to their customers maybe
they change them a little bit to be more
expected and then they show them to the
customers but I didn't hear many people
and I am looking for it so if you have a
story let me know after what I want to
hear people really using share values
for doing something so one thing you can
do with shop values is one thing one
basic thing is to just investing
investigate one specific prediction as
we talked about now one more interesting
thing you can do is to aggregate a lot
of shock values for many instances and
see some global view of your model and
this is an example I'm going to show
there are many more things you can do
you should go into there Ghita propose
see the example see the notebooks they
have also an outright paper explaining a
lot of aggregation I'm not gonna explain
all over them I will dive deeper into
the central aggregated explanation so
yeah get some kind of insight but once
you get from the higher level will get
another inside it's correlated with a
you can each other
so you can get a let's say a precise
description what is going to happen in
production about your order what is
affecting your own results because if
you see it in a macro level you will
have some idea but if you see it in a
low level you just mentioned that there
is a difference between looking at the
local or the global view there
the same they are not providing the same
insights of course yep of local or
global okay local I can talk to you
later but I think it's a much more
trivial the you digit of local you have
a problem your model predicted this is a
fraud but it is not it's like the paper
CEO and you blocked it and then okay you
get like someone's escalation what did
your model do so you want to investigate
but the global I will showcase one thing
here but there are much more cases if
you want just google it and see many
people try to explain and what they do
with global and views and I can also say
before joining paper I was in I did my
masters in it on Sega Islam and about
personalized nutrition and personalized
medicine and hug I feel so much and they
used a lot shop values in the global
view to investigate some really medical
features so you can take a look as well
of their papers and okay so you see this
view and if you are using shock values
or someone in your office uses shot
values you're gonna see it because it's
very easy to implement you just do shape
values dot summary plot and you get it
it's very easy now what is this quote
and why do we see here so let's break
this plot into details and understand
why do we see here so look at the left
side of the screen you see the whole
plot every row is a different feature i
said i'm aggregating shap values for
many instances and also for many
features what is the color the color is
the actual feature value for example
maybe the first feature is age and so
red values are older people and blue
values are younger people what is the x
axis the x axis is the shock value now
you can see it in the zoom in the shock
value can be 0 it means it did
actually impact the model result for
this instance but it can be high
positive value it means it pushed the
model in the model output up and it
could be minus large negative value and
it push the model output down so you can
see a lot of things here for example if
you take the right blue dot you see that
it has low value like a young person but
high shock value so it increased the
prediction however you look to the left
you look to the left then you see a red
dot this is an old person with negative
shop value it decreased the model score
you look in the middle you see many
values and you see the thick bars it's
just a distribution it's a jitter of the
dots many many dots every dot ISM
instance and you see many features the
didn't actually impact the model many
many instances for them the edge feature
didn't really impact the model
so again if you take a look on the
global view you can see something you
can see some pattern in your model and I
will show you a specific example how we
use this here every row is a single
feature this is an aggregate for 20
features ordered actually ordered by
their mean absolute shap values so that
we take the absolute because it could be
negative and positive so the absolute
here in represent the importance and we
can sort the values by their mean and
mean absolute values and then you see
the most important way the 20 most
important features for example most
important is debatable actually q what
does it mean most important but with
higher ash a higher mean shock value
impact okay so what is our specific
fraud case so obvious is here she works
on it this is a specific model we
trained to predict fraud of course
and we used only a specific type of
features features of consistency you can
imagine that consistency is important if
the person is more consistent it high it
is an high a higher chance for it to be
the account holder and if it's
inconsistent maybe this is a fraudster
so why consistency features do we have
for example cycle time consistency
product consistency and many consistency
features and we train the gbt query
inducing tree to predict if this is
fraud or not very trivial supervise the
scenario now we apply the shop values on
the results of this sound algorithm for
on the test set for example and we got
this plot now why do we use this
platform to gain trust in our model we
want to see that our model uses features
in the way that we as we have the domain
knowledge think it should do not all the
time you have domain knowledge not all
the time you know what the model should
do but sometimes you know and you want
to check that this is what your model
does in addition to test your accuracy
and everything so what our model does
our model take the blue dots to the
right it means that people that are
inconsistent with their past are more
prone to be fraudsters and this is
reasonable you see that the red dots are
going mostly to the left it means that
inconsistencies in the account are more
reasonable a consistencies in something
very consistent in the account is more
probable to be the account of the holder
and the fraud chances are lower so this
is a very global view I didn't say it is
correct for every single prediction
maybe even say that this is the way
every feature should look at but this is
the global view and it can help us get
trust in our model and just for a small
anecdote so if you run this with random
data you don't see this pattern
and this is also a way to debug whatever
you want and if you see the random data
you see much more dotted pattern that
it's not just all the Blues go here and
all the Reds go there it's much more
mess messy and you should maybe
investigate your model maybe you chose
the wrong version maybe this is not your
data set I don't know but this is a very
very easy way to implement something
they gave you a very nice global view of
your model ok that's it
our motivation was to look inside the
black box shop is a very nice way to do
it
it is theory based we can trust it we
can know what it does it's not just a
heuristic and it has a very practical
implementation so it's very easy to use
it has a lot of applications you can
investigate local model scores you can
see some global view but there are much
more if you take a look at recent
conferences you're going to see a lot of
people trying and starting using shape
values in more advanced ways for example
to find shifts in your data set to find
there is one paper discussing who is
more responsible to this court the model
or the data there are much more
implications that are starting to pop to
show up and therefore I think this is
increases the the importance of
understanding what our shop values
because there are some kind of basis
they have they have a lot a lot of
citations to their paper many people
starting to use it and if you don't
understand this it will be harder to
understand all the applications on top
of it and so that's it and I should say
that personally machine learning
explained ability is a very interesting
topic for me and I
we do it now these days we are working
on a project on how do we use tools like
shop and more to explain models but in
an action bill in an actionable manner
for example I don't want just to see the
values I want to do something I want to
help my customers understand the
predictions use them better something
like this and if you are working on
explain ability or you doing some
research about it please send me a
message I really want to connect we are
started connecting people from this
field and I am creating a sub community
or something like this and so I would be
happy to take questions the question is
if we use it for multi-class problem so
I think yes why not you want to explain
the prediction and you mean move the
class whenever you predict a few
possible outputs I didn't do it but I
everybody else someone as an announcer
yeah it works we work ok I said yeah yes
ok so the question is there is a lot of
criticism about using external method to
explain models actually this is called
post hoc explanations you train a model
and then you try to explain predictions
and there is a criticism about a lot of
explanation thing this is an ongoing
research there is no like there way to
explain things my view is that you
should first define what do you want as
an explanation like what is your
audience what do you try to explain
there are many different solutions one
solution can be to train a more
transparent model there are models like
this IBM of Microsoft if you heard about
it but the problem of these models for
example in PayPal I won't change all
people's production models now right I
have already very good models
explanation is like the
next level but first level is to prevent
fraud so this is where the postdoc
explanations are really really useful
yes just to make sure I understood in
the last couple of slides you showed an
example where the model lever you
measure the sensitivity of the model not
just to the existence of the feature but
whether it's present or not but to the
actual value how seldom it is to a
certain age range so how does it is that
implemented actually you only make it
the feature disappear okay what what I
show here is the actual shaft values
after I cut every dot in this plot is
their final shock value after you did
all of this subs sample subsets and
music features and that that's the final
shock value it's the average of the
marginal contribution of this feature
for this instance so you calculate it
using the shop algorithms I showed in
this lecture this is actually the shop
values you get the final result of plunk
shop we can discuss later okay yes okay
you asked why do what am I looking for
when I'm looking at this specific plot
so this is a good question there is no
one answer specifically in this model we
try to make sure that the model is using
the feature in the way we think it
should it should use the consistency in
one direction inconsistent fraud not
going to a consistent not from and if it
doesn't do it it's a specious something
is weird maybe it's some overfitting or
something like this but for different
type of use cases you might be looking
for something else here we just looked
at the pattern okay so I'll be happy to
take questions later and thank you very
much for listening
[Applause]